- Hi everyone, Sal here from Khan Academy,
welcome again for joining
our homeroom live stream.
Before we get into what's gonna
be a really fun conversation
with some internal Khan
Academy team members to talk
about all the new things
we have for back to school,
I will make my standard announcements.
First of all a reminder that Khan Academy
is a not-for-profit
organization, we can only exist
through donations from
folks like yourself,
so if you're in a position
to do so, please think
about making a donation
at khanacademy.org/donate.
I also wanna make a special shout out
to several organizations
that when they learned
that we were running at a
deficit even before COVID
and that deficit only grew
because our server costs
have gone up, we're trying
to accelerate a whole series
of programs and and content
here at Khan Academy,
they stepped up to help us
fill that gap, Bank of America,
Google.org, AT and T, Fastly, Novartis
and also thanks to the Amgen foundation.
Even with that very significant
support we are continuing
to run at a gap, at a very
large gap actually as we go
into next fiscal year.
So if you're in a position
to do so, please think
about making a donation to Khan Academy.
With that I'm excited to
introduce two of my colleagues,
Dan and Sophie to talk about
some of what we have going
on here at Khan Academy
in the coming months,
hey Dan, hey Sophie?
- Hi Sal.
- So Dan, and we have to
come up with better terms,
'cause we have Khan Academy
kids and then we have the rest
of Khan Academy which we're starting
to sometimes call big Khan
Academy, but you don't have
to be big or physically
big to use Khan Academy.
But let's start with a big Khan Academy,
I'll turn to you Dan for that,
so what do we have going on?
And I also wanna a reminder
to everyone watching, put
your questions and you can view
this as an ask us anything,
not just of me but also of Dan and Sophie
for everything going on with
Khan Academy can be related
to what Dan and Sophie are
gonna be talking about,
or anything that is on your mind.
So we have team members
who are gonna help surface
some of those questions.
So, sorry, I interrupted you Dan.
What do we have going on Dan?
- Yep, thanks Sal, so
for everyone just wanted
to call out at Khan
Academy here, as educators,
as parents and as lifelong
learners, we empathize
with all that you're
going through right now,
many of us are going through
the exact same things,
and Khan Academy is here to help.
So first of all, all the
resources that we created
when this whole crisis
started in the spring,
we've updated them all and
they're still all available,
so from the daily schedules,
how to get started
with Khan Academy, to everything's located
on the keeplearning.khanacademy.org
which is also available
in Spanish right now.
And I would say really
excited, one of the things
that we heard loud and clear
from teachers, students
and parents for the back to
school, is the number one thing
that's being requested, is
how do we keep motivated
to learn in a distance environment?
And so I'm excited to announce two things
that we're doing for back to school.
The first one is LearnStorm.
So LearnStorm kicked off this
Monday, and for those of you
who don't know LearnStorm
is our engaging fun
motivating classroom campaign,
where students work
independently but it's towards
a shared classroom goal,
and really it has academic
content, it focuses
on growth mindset, and it
has motivation mechanics.
For this year we're really
excited because we adapted it
for distance learning, so
we're connecting teachers
and the students to one another,
really trying to ensure
that learning continues
to spark that joy, and we're
emphasizing digital prizes
and tips to keep distance
learning successful.
And all of that's available
on our LearnStorm hub,
and that's at learnstorm.khabacademy.org.
And then secondly most
exciting thing that,
I'm really excited about is,
is the distance learning
survival guide for parents.
So we heard loud and
clear from parents that
there's a really big challenge
in getting kids motivated
throughout for distance learning.
And so the guide really has
three areas, the Set-up,
which also includes things
like how to set up your space,
how to set up your time
for distance learning.
The second piece which uh
is all around motivation,
so Kristine who's our chief
learning officer, wrote
a starting article on
how to kind of set goals
and how to keep your kids motivated,
and that's a section that
we'll build on over time.
And the third piece is around
self-care, so we recognize
as parents, if you're not
in a good place the kids
will recognize that and they
won't be in a good place
as well, so we wanna be mindful that,
to help you as parents and as caregivers,
to be mindful about yourselves.
And so I wanna highlight
the motivation piece
'cause there's one piece that's
really exciting which is,
how to set up your goals,
how to think about motivation
and for that section
we'll be adding new pieces
and new articles
throughout the entire fall.
So, and that's available
at khan.co/distancelearningsurvivalguide.
- Yeah and I'll just add
to everything that Dan
and the incredible team
here that's been partnering
with schools and families to
put this out, has been doing
but and we've talked about
this at previous live streams,
but just a reminder,
everything Dan has talked about
is on top of everything else
going on at Khan Academy.
Obviously, we have all,
especially in math starting
with pre-k we'll talk about
Khan Academy kids in a second,
but going to elementary
middle high school math,
kids can learn at their own
time and pace, teachers, parents
can have dashboards to
understand where kids are.
We also over the Summer in
preparation for back to school,
especially this COVID
back to school launched,
our get ready for grade level courses
which we've talked about before.
But that's a way to make sure that kids
have a strong foundation
and to really understand,
are they ready for the
grade level courses or not,
if they are great, if they
aren't, they can go back up
and on work on those things.
Sophie I'll turn to you,
Khan Academy Kids is still
a relatively new thing, it's been out
for almost two years now.
But if you could just,
before we even talk about all
of the new things we
have for back to school,
just give everyone a reminder
on what Khan Academy Kids is?
- Yeah, hi Sal, Khan Academy
Kids is Khan Academy's program
for two to seven-year-olds,
so it's for our youngest learners.
And it's a mobile app,
so you can download it
on your mobile device, your
tablet or touchscreen Chromebook
from whatever app store you use.
And it's really designed to
get kids ready for kindergarten
and to thrive beyond that.
And it's full of activities,
so it covers math,
reading, social emotional
learning, we get kids up
and moving so they're
not glued to screens,
it there's a creative
corner, it's really diverse.
The whole idea being there's much more
than just pure academics when
it comes to getting kids ready
to thrive at school.
And so we've been around like
you said so for not so long
for a couple of years and
been beloved by families.
And I don't think anything
could have really prepared us
for the school closures
in march and the demand
that we would see not just
from families who were using
our app for a long time at
home, but also from teachers
who needed a way to keep kids
learning even from a distance,
they needed to somehow
connect with little kids
who were stuck at home and make
sure that they were learning
everything they needed to
be ready to go to school
and get through school and thrive.
So we've got some exciting
things that I'd love
to share with you, we
launched Teacher Tools,
for teachers to connect
with their students,
and we're seeing a little demo of it here,
we're seeing a teacher who's setting up
their teacher account.
And one of the really cool
things Sal is that teachers
can actually add their students
at different developmental levels.
So that's gonna help
teachers personalize learning
for kids who are at home,
even from a distance.
They can have kids who
are about to see it now,
who are in kindergarten, they
can accelerate to first grade.
And then teachers can search by standard,
we're aligned to the head start
early learning outcomes framework
and common core standards.
They can find activities
that they wanna assign
to an individual student,
a group of students
or their whole class, and
we're scanning through all
of that beautiful content
now that they can assign.
And then crucially, they
can see how their students
are going, they can see by
student, they can see by standard
and checking on their entire
class, we're about to see
that now for an add equations assignment
that a teacher has assigned.
We can pop that up and see,
oh, John hasn't attempted,
Ringo is struggling, Kim's struggling,
and we can really get a good
sense of where our kids are at,
even while we as teachers
are at home and our kids
are stuck at home too.
So I'm excited about Teacher Tools,
it's the first time Khan
Academy Kids has done something
for teachers, it was designed by teachers
with the help of teachers.
And if you're a teacher
and you're interested
in checking it out, download the app
and set yourself up as a teacher.
If you're a parent and you're interested
in using Khan Academy Kids
at home with your teacher,
your child's teacher,
then I'd encourage you
to check out khankids.org,
that's khankids.org and that link there
to distance learning is
where parents can go to find
everything they need to get started,
and you'll see right behind it
is the link to Teacher Tools,
where teachers can go
to figure out how to get
their class set up, add
their kids and get learning.
So over to you Sal,
that's what's happening
at Khan Academy Kids this back to school.
- Know super exciting,
and I wanna emphasize
everything Sophie mentioned
and Dan mentioned,
this is all free,
non-commercial, non-profit,
there's no catch here, the catch
is my earlier announcement,
we're philanthropically funded.
So if you're in a position
to do so please donate.
So there's a bunch of
questions that are coming in
over Youtube and Facebook.
This first one is for you
Sophie, this is from Facebook
Shenaz Gilani asks, after a long thought
I've decided to homeschool my first grader
for the upcoming year, is Khan Academy's
offered program sufficient to
help him through this process
and prepare him for second grade
for the next year, the year
after, or should I look
for other curricula
as well to supplement his learning,
how do you think about that?
- Yeah, so, hi Shenaz, so
our content is fully aligned
to the common core
standards for first grade.
So you'll see all the
math and ELA standards
that your child needs
covered in our program.
I think with anything though
with this distance learning,
having a balanced curriculum
and having different resources
to supplement things
is always a great idea.
I would say Khan Academy Kids
is an excellent starting
point, you can rest assured
that it's fully aligned to those standards
that your child will need to be learning,
to get up to second grade and thrive.
And it would be great to be supplemented
by other great resources out
there and lots of balanced play
and outdoor time and life
skills at home as well.
- And just to underline
what you said Sophie is,
obviously you wouldn't
wanna just stick a kid
in front of Khan Academy
Kids and then leave the room
so to speak, but Khan Academy Kids,
it does cover math, reading, writing
and social emotional learning
aligned with the standards.
So if a child is able to
uh work on those standards
over the course of the
year, and we're talking
about maybe a couple of
sessions of 20 minutes a day
or maybe 15 minutes,
and a couple of sessions
of 15 minutes a day.
If you do that over time, we
have some efficacy studies
that it does seem to for sure
help kids learn or learn a lot
and then the parents can
feel pretty confident
that they're familiar, that
they know the standards,
and really they've mastered the standards
as they go into second grade.
- Yeah, that's right Sal.
- Let's see, there's other questions here.
So, a lot of folks and I
could probably take this one,
from Facebook Heather Reading Maffioli,
any chance of elementary science based
on the next generation science
standards for K through 5?
So we hear you and we would love to do it,
and obviously COVID has made the need
for having elementary
and middle school science
that much more important.
We have a lot of high
school and I would say,
early college science
already on Khan Academy.
But unfortunately we
don't have the resources
to work on that just yet.
And so the resources to
do that properly actually
would be pretty significant,
so if you know any foundations
out there that are
interested, especially in,
I think this was a huge
need even pre-COVID,
but you can imagine
the need has only grown
so that we can hopefully build
out our science progression,
eventually from K through
12, which is our goal,
and our mission as I said
we already have a lot
at the high school level.
So there's a question and
this maybe I could take it,
but I'm happy if Dan and
Sophie wanna jump in.
From youtube Yumna says,
can you help me resolve
one of my problems, my
eldest son does not take
his studies seriously, he avoids studying.
I think this is a central
problem, I think in most
of academics, main barrier
to actually learning the academic material
is just engagement.
And I think students at different
ages, at different stages
in their academic development disengage
for different reasons,
I fundamentally believe,
and we've seen this, I've
seen this anecdotally
at Khan Academy, we've even
seen a little bit of data
that kids disengage when
they feel like the content
is not for them, when
is either not applicable to
their life, they feel like
it's too easy for them and they're bored,
or they feel like it's too hard for them.
And so I think a lot of what
we try to do at Khan Academy
is first of all, offer content
that can be personalized
to where the student is.
So what I would do is, I don't
know how old your eldest son
is, but have them, if they say
they're entering sixth grade,
have them take the course
challenge on Khan Academy
for the getting ready
for sixth grade course.
And that getting ready for,
that way you'll be able
to, you and your son will
be able to understand
how ready they are for sixth grade,
and if they aren't they
can fill in those gaps
over time, and then uh they
can work at their own time
and pace at the sixth grade.
And to motivate them, I would remind them,
you could hopefully they're
watching, you can remind them
that this is really interesting stuff
that's going to be really
valuable for their entire life.
But what I've seen is as people
get their legs under them
and they start to master the concepts,
they actually really start
enjoying the learning process.
I'd also recommend making
it a point of interaction
between you and your child.
Maybe you're doing your
work from home now,
do it right next to
them, so they say, hey,
let's work together for 20 minutes
and then we're gonna take
a 10-minute break together,
let's work together for 30 minutes,
then we're gonna take a
10-minute break together.
I think that might make it a lot more fun
for your child, or they
could do that with some
of their friends to
kind of keep them going,
to have some positive peer pressure,
so those are my thoughts.
On the Sophie, Dan any
ideas on if a parent
has a particularly, a child that seems
to be a little disengaged?
- Yeah, so I would echo
a lot of the things
that you already mentioned,
so in our article
on how to motivate,
Kristine's article on that.
I think the two things
she called out is one,
people are more likely to
do something if they think
they're successful at it.
And then number two, they're
more likely also to do
if they value that activity.
So in our motivation article,
there's a couple recommendations,
first, is to make sure
that you talk to your
child about the goals
and making sure that
there's a shared goal.
Number two, is just
making sure that the child
is actually working towards this goal,
so to monitoring progress.
And I think most importantly
is also to make sure
that you talk to the child
about how those goals relate
to their values.
So is it a passion that
they're interested in,
or what do they get out of
it in the long term as well.
So I think those are the important things.
And then also if they
get stuck at something,
so this speaks to being
successful, if they get stuck
with something that you have a process
to help them get out of, to be unblocked.
- Yeah, Sophie for the younger kids?
- Yeah, for younger kids
one thing that we've seen
that's really worked and
you touched on this Sal
is really linking the learning with play
and what's going on outside
of the online experience.
So we've had, over the
summer we had a summer camp
and one of the most popular
things was a scavenger hunt,
and it really was teaching counting.
There was accounting
exercising, a grouping exercise,
but what it amounted to was
kids really getting outdoors
or even in their apartments
or wherever they were,
getting moving, being
curious, finding things,
getting up and about and
talking to their family
about what they were finding,
and that has been one way
that we have seen kids
really get into the learning.
- Yeah, and the summer camp you mentioned,
it was a digital summer
camp and so you were able
to engage kids even, given
the not so ideal circumstances
that we are now facing.
So this next question
from Facebook, and I think
I could at least take a first tab at this.
Sally Vorhies says, are there tests to see
what math level I should start with?
So Sally, I don't know if you're a student
or if you're a parent,
but let's say whether
you're student or parent
we're talking about
you're entering let's say seventh grade.
What I would recommend is
we have in math something
called a get ready for
seventh grade course.
And what you can do is go to that course,
and it'll actually prompt you to take
what's called a Course
Challenge, which samples
from the entire course
for the get-ready-for.
So this is all the foundational
skills for seventh grade.
If you do well on that,
say, you get an 80 or 90%,
that means that you're
ready for seventh grade,
and so then you can start
working at your own time and pace
on the seventh grade course.
If you aren't doing well on
that initial course challenge,
if you're getting a 50% to 60% on it,
or even lower, that means
that you have some gaps
in your knowledge uh that
are prerequisite skills
for seventh grade.
And then you can use that
get-ready-for seventh grade course
to go focus on the units that
you're having trouble with,
and then get mastery in
those skills, so that you can
have a strong foundation, and then you
can feel confident going
into seventh grade.
If you're already starting
seventh grade, there's two ways
to do it, you can front
load with the get-ready
for grade level course
like I just talked about,
or you could do it in parallel to,
while you're doing your
seventh grade course
at your own time and pace.
So I would say, generally
speaking, if you're student
or if you're the parent of a student,
the system, the school
system has some grade
that the the child is entering
or that you are entering,
but we know that everyone
has different gaps
in their knowledge, they
have different levels
of preparedness, and so
that's why we created
these get-ready-for grade level courses,
so that you have an opportunity to fill in
all your prerequisite gaps that you need,
so that you have a strong
foundation for your grade level.
And clearly if you find, if
you're ready for seventh grade
and maybe even you know a lot
of the seventh grade material
you could take the course challenge there,
we have a bunch of acceleration mechanics,
course challenges, unit
tests, mastery challenges
so you can move through
that quickly if you know
that material, and you can
imagine some seventh graders
might be even ready for eighth
or even ninth grade material.
So everything we do here at
Khan Academy is to help you find
your learning edge, but
I would definitely start
with whatever grade level
you're entering in math,
and we have these get
ready grade level courses
all the way through pre-calculus.
And obviously we have
grade level all the way
through calculus, but whatever
grade level you're starting
take the course challenge
on the get-ready-for
grade level course, if you do well go
into the grade level course
learn that at your own time
and pace, if you didn't do so well, focus
on the get-ready-for grade level course
so you have a strong foundation.
Anything to add maybe Dan to that?
- Yes, I would just say
that the course challenges
are not particularly long,
so it's not like that
you have to invest three
hours to take the test,
to take that little quiz, so
I think that's a great way
to start to just orient
yourself with the materials.
- So the next question, a question I think
this is for Sophie
from Facebook Maria Mong
asks, I have an eager four
and a half year old
who's beginning to read,
do you suggest any particular courses?
He will not start school
until he's five and a half due
to the age cutoff really eager to begin,
do we test him first,
what do you think Sophie?
- Yeah, I mean, I think that when it comes
to Khan Academy Kids an eager
four and a half year old
who's beginning to read is
exactly the target market,
we have thousands of
books and they can be read
to your child or your
child can read aloud.
I would really encourage some co-plays
or getting involved in
that and having a parent
or a caregiver working with
your child through that.
I think it's a great place to start,
and it will obviously
take him beyond reading,
it'll be the full range of
those pre-literacy skills
that your child really needs
to be ready for kindergarten,
and also math and social
emotional learning
and a bunch of other things in there.
So I would recommend an eager
four and a half year old
start with Khan Academy Kids and I think
you'll see that reading
really pick up in no time
a lot of our research shows that,
we see really big gains over
periods of like 10 or 12 weeks
when kids are that young
and learning that quickly,
with their pre-literacy,
so that's an exciting time.
- Yeah, couldn't agree more,
and many of you all know
I have a five and a
half year old, so I can,
he was actually in those
original, I guess you
could call them ads or
for Khan Academy Kids,
he's a kid that keeps screaming every time
I'm trying to talk properly.
But yes Khan Academy Kids has
been very effective with him,
it's very engaging, Sophie
and the team have done
a really incredible
job, I really can't take
much credit for it for their work.
Another, it's a related question
from Facebook, Grace Han,
can you offer an audio
function for math at least
for the early years, my
daughter's still learning
to read going into first
grade, but really enjoys math,
it would also, it would
be so helpful to include
a function that reads the question to her
so that she can work independently.
So, I have, I'll take a
first stab at and Sophie
might have something to add.
So Grace I think what you're
referring to is if you go
to our, I guess you guys call it big con,
if you go to our website or if you use
our the formal Khan Academy
mobile app or tablet app,
what you see is we have
content that goes as early
as early learning, kind
of the early kindergarten,
first grade standards, and
it's offered up, the practice
is offered up in a modality very similar
to the rest of Khan Academy,
where there's questions,
you might have to input either
a choice or input a number
in some way shape or form,
and you can imagine for kids
who are five or six
years old they might not
be littered enough or have
necessarily the motor skills
to fully do that.
And so I have two points of advice,
one is, Khan Academy
Kids is a great solution,
it sounds like your child or your daughter
is entering first grade,
so Khan Academy Kids
already has the first grade
standards in math on it,
and Khan Academy Kids was
designed for that age group,
so it's very visual,
it's audio, it's video,
it's everything these
folks that, these kids need
that are kind of right at that cusp
of early reading and literacy.
If you wanna use kind of big Khan Academy,
a lot of that material
we see as a use case
of maybe a slightly older child who needs
some remediation, they might use that.
But it can also be used
if you find that modality
that's kind of a more traditional modality
of getting a lot of
practice and then getting
some support videos when necessary.
I would recommend being
able to sit next to them,
and work on them, work with it that way.
Unfortunately we the audio
functionality is a great idea,
we just haven't had the
bandwidth to do that yet.
Anything to add Sophie?
- Yeah, I would say on the Khan Kids side,
it has been really important
to have that narrator Kodi Bear
really reading the questions out
and guiding our younger
learners through their learning.
And so that there are
certainly audio prompts,
explaining the question
and helping students along
on Khan Academy Kids.
- Yeah, super helpful, so from
Facebook there's a question
of Sanderson ask, would
you say Khan Academy
is inclusive to support
students with disabilities?
So Sander it's an excellent question
and one that we've gotten
many times over the years,
I mean, it really depends what
the needs of the child are.
I would say that there's
an ongoing and process
to make Khan Academy as
accessible as possible,
we there's different
thresholds of accessibility
and we're on that journey,
so I don't wanna claim
that we are fully
accessible for everyone yet,
but we're constantly
striving there for students
who are hearing impaired, we
have subtitles closed captions
on our videos that, they're
actually for the most part done
by a lot of volunteers, so
thank you all volunteers.
We're trying to make the
site itself much more useful
and consistent and being able to work
with various kind of aid type apps.
And we've heard anecdotally
depending on the special need,
learning needs of the child
that it can be very useful
depending on where the the child is,
but we're on a journey, is I
guess a simple way to say that.
We definitely aren't
as far as one could be,
and we also haven't done, we've
done many efficacy studies
on, there's over 50 efficacy
studies that have been done
on Khan Academy, but these have been more
with kind of larger population,
so we haven't had a chance
yet to do it with special
needs populations.
But we've had some
anecdotal things depending
on what those special needs are,
but that's our current state of affairs.
So, there's a question from
YouTube, Joshua Cataville,
how should we know what courses to follow
on Khan Academy based
on what we wanna learn
at our current grade level?
Is there a career we wanna
follow, how do we know
what classes to take on Khan Academy?
So the first part of it, you
could look at your grade level,
let's say I'll use the same
example I used a few minutes ago
of let's say you're a seventh grader,
you could go to Khan Academy
we have get-ready-for grade level courses,
and there you can take
the course challenge.
And if you do really
well on that, that means
you have the foundations needed
to enter into seventh grade,
if you're not do not so
well on it, not a big deal,
you can go into that course
and then focus on the units
and the skills so that
you can get mastery,
so you have a strong
foundation for seventh grade.
Then you could go into the
seventh grade course, work
on that at your own time
and pace and you'll be able
to progress and if you feel
like the seventh grade course
is easy, you could take
the course challenge there,
the unit test there and
accelerate through that
and move on to eighth grade.
So that would be my advice
on start at your grade level
and the get-ready-for grade level course,
if you're ready for grade
level, just move right
into that at your own time, pace,
if you need help
get-ready-for grade level,
if you're ready to move ahead you can go
obviously beyond your grade level.
In terms of connecting the
learning on Khan Academy
to careers really the
second part or interest
of your question, we don't
have super robust mechanisms
for that right now.
I would say and feel
free to add what career
you're thinking about,
I could give you more specific advice.
But I will tell you that
pretty much any career
that you go into, people
are going ti want to ensure
that you have strong analytical
and critical thinking skills
and it isn't just that
people are trying to give you
a hard time, strong analytical
and critical thinking skills
are really valuable in
almost every career.
And it is true that
there are certain careers
where you actually might
solve a system of equations
or actually might solve a quadratic.
I actually did find myself
doing both of those things
every now and then when I
used to work in finance,
and when I used to work
in computer science.
But the ability to learn these
things and think through it
and deduce it and really
understand it are skills
that are portable to almost any field,
and that's why so many folks
I would say especially care
about learning things like uh algebra.
I remember one of the early
supporters of Khan Academy ran
a large restaurant chain, very large,
a publicly traded company,
and he used to say
that he divides his
employees based on whether
they know algebra or not.
He actually that's his main
deciding factor on whether
they have the critical thinking
skills and the independence
and the agency to be
able to become a manager,
or a regional manager
eventually become an executive
in the organization, and that's
for a restaurant business,
that's not for someone
who's a software firm,
or a engineering firm
where the math or finance,
where the math or the science
is that much more valuable.
And that's just the math
side, I would also say
and that Khan Academy
right now we definitely
have the whole pathway in math from pre-K
with Khan Academy Kids, all the way
through elementary, middle,
high school and early college.
We have sciences and things
like SAT prep in high school,
but even the things where Khan Academy
does not offer things, I
encourage you to get as strong
as possible, during COVID
try to write as much
as possible, write blogs,
share things with folks,
write stories, get feedback,
journal as much as you can,
'cause I can't tell you how
important that writing skill
is in your life.
I do, in pretty much any
career today you're gonna
do more writing than anything else,
especially a lot of the
careers that I suspect
you might aspire to.
Same thing for reading,
you cannot read too much,
and I would say that's pretty
much true of every career
to just be able to read, communicate,
have the critical thinking
skills going to be
very, very, very valuable for you.
So, oh, it looks like Joshua
is in engineering related career.
Well, then it's even
more directly valuable,
you actually will use the
algebra, the geometry,
the trigonometry, the
calculus, the statistics
in your engineering, so
it's directly applicable.
And the humanities and the
language arts are also gonna
become very important.
My original degree was in computer science
and electrical engineering,
I worked in technology
as kind of the first wave of my career.
And I can't tell you how
important it has been
to be able to write, communicate,
have strong reading comprehension,
and now Khan Academy,
a lot of our team are engineers, people
with technical backgrounds,
and one of the top skills
is obviously they are, they
need to be able to design
and write code well and engineer well,
but a lot of it is
collaboration, communication,
being able to read and
understand the direction
of the organization.
So, all of this stuff really matters
especially if you're going
to become an engineer,
but pretty much any career.
So let's see, if other
questions is Facebook.
Lee Lam asks, if students are
behind because of the pandemic
how are they gonna manage their time
to do grade level assignments
homework and assignments
they are behind in?
I think each student will need
an individualized learning
plan with organizational,
learning path with organizational skills.
I agree with you Lee, I actually
think what you described
is actually in any year,
even if we weren't dealing
with a pandemic, we know that
kids show up the first day
of school with at all different levels.
And in the ideal world we would be able
to personalize the pace,
the scope, what we cover
to their individual needs,
make sure they can fill in
their gaps, and that's why
so much of our resources
at Khan Academy are focused
on not only creating content,
not only creating exercises
and videos that are helpful,
but creating software that
students know how to navigate it
and navigate at their own time and pace,
they get different levels
of mastery on the skills,
parents and teachers can
monitor where those kids are.
And that's also why we
created these things,
these get-ready-for grade level courses.
We've always seen really
good results when teachers
have students start at the
basics on Khan Academy,
fill in all their gaps
and get to grade level,
and they get-ready-for grade level course
has really streamlined that process.
So we're hoping that
especially in this pandemic,
but even beyond this pandemic
that Khan Academy really
is the place that people go
to for free, non-commercial,
not-for-profit but really
world-class personalized practice
with immediate feedback that
has other supports, videos,
hints, solutions, information
to adults to help that student
so that kids can learn at their
own time and pace, fill in
any gaps they need and then keep,
and then to keep going.
Let's see other questions
here from Facebook,
Jin Sugar Brown says,
how can the Khan Academy
bring inclusive education across Africa,
any initiative happening
here that you can share?
A great question Jin, so we we
have 46 translation projects
of Khan Academy around
the world, these are
for the most part volunteer driven.
I know that there's
several going on in Africa,
I believe there's one in
Afrikaans, there's one in Swahili
and obviously we have projects
in french, large
french-speaking populations
in large parts of Africa,
but I would encourage you
to look at the Khan
Academy advocate program,
the advocates are the
volunteers who've been doing
these various translation projects.
So depending what region,
what language in Africa
you are thinking about, there
might already be a project
to translate or to redo Khan
Academy in that geography.
And there are all different
levels of fidelity depending
on where they are in that journey
and how well resourced they are.
And if you don't see your
language and wanted to see it,
maybe you could be one of the advocates
or you can find a group of
folks who can start that effort
in your geography in your language.
So let's see, from this is
a question from Facebook,
Praveen Pal, my daughter is
three and a half years old,
will be taking nursery class, can we start
with your course material?
And I think Sophie might
have had to drop off,
I can take a first stab at this,
simple interest, oh,
Sophie's there even better.
So Sophie Praveen's daughter
is three and a half years old,
can we start her on Khan Academy Kids,
and how would you recommend doing that?
- Yeah, so Sal absolutely,
I think starting
on Khan Academy Kids with
a three and a half year old
is a great plan, so the
logistics side of it,
you download our app from your app store,
and you can quickly set up an account
and add your child's profile there.
And then what I would
recommend is there's actually
a big play button in
the center when you come
into the home screen,
and that is a personalized learning path.
So if you set up your three
and a half year old, say,
as an age three profile
on Khan Academy Kids.
That personalized learning
path will actually serve up
a mixture of reading of math
of social emotional learning,
all the things your child
needs to be kindergarten ready,
at their pace, and it will
adapt, it will get smart
to where your child is at.
And I think that's probably
a great way to start.
Obviously lots of parents
differ on screen time
for a child of that
age and we really defer
to the American Association
of Pediatrics on that.
What our research shows is that between
about 15 and 25 minutes a
day depending on the age
of your child, maybe
three to five times a week
is where we start to really see
those learning gains pick up
and enjoy I would say go for it.
- Awesome, well I just
noticed the time goes a lot,
I thought we were only
like 10 minutes into this,
we're already at 12:35,
so I will wrap it up,
we're gonna continue to be here,
we have a exciting conversation tomorrow
with Linda Darling-Hammond,
education expert,
Stanford professor involved
in government as well
to talk about distance learning,
so excited about that tomorrow.
But I just wanna remind
everyone, all of us here
at Khan Academy, I wanna
thank Sophie and Dan.
We're trying to do everything
we can to support you,
even pre-COVID but especially as COVID,
as people doing distance
learning to support you,
your parents, your teachers
so that we can all hold hands
and get through this together.
It's gonna be a hard year in
a lot of ways, but I think
it's also an opportunity
for us to try new things
and to make sure that we
can all collectively support
each other and keep learning.
I will make the announcement
just to remind folks that,
if any of y'all have been
enjoying these podcasts
or these lecture or these live streams,
and want a podcast version of it,
there is a podcast
version Homeroom with Sal,
I guess the podcast I actually
wasn't involved in naming,
but i like the name, the
podcast, Homeroom the podcast,
which you can get wherever
you would find podcasts,
whether it's you're on android or apple
or wherever else people get podcasts.
So take a look at that,
it's not all of our episodes
but many of them are kind
of edited for podcast
in kind of a listening format.
So with that super excited
to see y'all tomorrow,
the conversation with
Linda Darling-Hammond,
and as always, if in a
position to do so, please think
about making a donation to
Khan Academy, thanks everyone.